determina el área del rombo abc de
dado que los radios de las
circunferencias circunscritas a los
triángulos abed y hace de son 12.5 y 25
respectivamente
ok déjame hacer un dibujo por aquí por
aquí voy a pintar uno de los lados del
rombo ahí tenemos un lado por acá voy a
pintar otro estos dos tienen que medir
lo mismo para que realmente sea un rombo
ahí tenemos el tercer lado y finalmente
el cuarto lado lo voy a pintar así va
entonces ahí tenemos un rombo más o
menos decente voy a llamarle a sus
vértices a b c y d ok ahora lo que nos
dicen es que tenemos información acerca
del radio de los círculos círculos de
ave de ideas de entonces déjame trazar
los triángulos abed y hace de para ave
de nada más falta está esta diagonal del
rombo y para hacer falta estaré acá muy
bien recordemos que las diagonales de un
rombo son perpendiculares bueno entonces
tenemos que son perpendiculares este es
igual a este que es igual este que es
igual a este y lo que nos dicen es
la circunferencia circunscrita a abb
tiene radio 12.5 entonces déjame
dibujarla es decir un centro más o menos
va a quedar por acá un poquito más a la
izquierda quizás y ahí está ahí tenemos
la circunferencia que pasa por ave y de
entonces ese es el circo círculo de este
triángulo y nos dicen que ese círculo
tiene radio igual a 12.5
entonces voy a trazar ahí este radio
vamos a suponer que este es el círculo
centro y aquí tiene radio 12.5 vale 12.5
lo voy a poner un poco lo voy a poner
acá arriba para que se vea 12.5 bueno
ahora vamos con el otro triángulo con el
acd también vamos a dibujar su
circunferencia circunscrita o bien
círculo yo creo que más o menos ha de
estar como por aquí el centro vamos a
ver si es cierto tenemos algo así para
no estar está un poquito chueco el
círculo pero no le hace más o menos se
ve la idea verdad y lo que nos dan
información es que el círculo radio en
este caso es igual a 25 entonces la
distancia del cirque un centro a algún
vértice es igual a 25 muy bien ahora lo
que nosotros queremos hacer es
determinar el área de abc de pero sólo
tenemos información de circulación cómo
le podemos hacer para utilizar esta
información pues justo acabamos de ver
en un vídeo anterior una fórmula que
relaciona circunda dios con áreas cuando
tenemos un triángulo entonces
a lo mejor quiere revisar este vídeo
para acordarte de la fórmula pero bueno
la voy a escribir aquí de todas formas
básicamente lo que decía la fórmula es
que si tenemos un triángulo abc entonces
entonces el círculo radio el círculo
radio del triángulo es igual al producto
de los lados del triángulo a por b por c
dividido entre cuatro veces el área le
voy a poner así cuatro veces el área
el área vale bueno entonces la idea es
utilizar esta fórmula para resolver el
problema vamos a ver si esta fórmula nos
da información y de ahí encontramos
información acerca del área de ave de
ideas de y con eso podemos encontrar el
área de abc de ba bueno déjame dibujar
otro rombo porque aquí ya todo está muy
encima entonces voy a pintar otro rombo
por acá vamos a poner este lado este
otro lado y ahorita ya no nos vamos a
preocupar por por dibujar los círculos
porque eso lo amontona las cosas y ya
tenemos esta fórmula de acá bueno
entonces ahí tenemos el rombo va a ser
el rumbo a bs de abc de ahí tenemos a b
c y d y vamos a dibujar sus diagonales
entonces vamos a pintar por acá la
diagonal bebé y la diagonal cede y
sabemos por otros vídeos que hemos hecho
que estas diagonales son perpendiculares
de hecho más aún verdad sabemos que son
media triz es entre sí es decir ésta es
perpendicular a esta y pasa por su punto
medio de modo que este segmento es igual
este de acá
y de modo similar hace es media triz dvd
entonces es perpendicular y también pasa
por su punto medio entonces este es
igual a este de acá van bueno entonces
observa si quisiéramos determinar el
área del rombo lo que tendríamos que
hacer es determinar el área de cada uno
de estos triángulos y después sumar
todas esas áreas pero si nos damos
cuenta estos cuatro triángulos son
congruentes por qué pues porque todos
esos triángulos tienen tienen el lado
azul tienen el lado naranja y tienen
este lado que estoy marcando en rojo lo
del lado en rojo es porque como es un
rombo los cuatro lados son iguales va
entonces estos cuatro triángulos son
congruentes y por lo tanto para
determinar el área del rombo bastaría
con encontrar el área de uno de estos
triángulos y multiplicar por cuatro
déjame ponerle nombres a las cosas
entonces a esta longitud le voy a llamar
ve a la longitud de acá le voy a llamar
a voy a llamar a
entonces tenemos que encontrar el área
de este triángulo vale tenemos que
encontrar ahí b y con esos
encontraríamos que el área de ese
triángulo estoy aquí
sería igual a un medio de la base por la
altura entonces el área de esta región
marcada en blanco es un medio un medio
de a por b por b y de esta forma el área
del rombo abc de lo voy a poner aquí
arriba el área del rombo a b c d sería
igual a 4 porque tenemos cuatro de esos
triángulos multiplicado por un medio x x
b y esto de aquí es igual a dos veces a
b
de esta forma basta encontrar a y b para
poder encontrar el área del rombo bueno
pues para encontrar a ive vamos a
utilizar esta fórmula a ver qué nos dice
ba observemos que éste de acá también es
b y que este de acá también es a destaca
también es bueno entonces vamos a
utilizar esta fórmula con la primera
información que nos da que el área del
triángulo a vd o más bien que el círculo
radio del triángulo abed es 12.5
entonces voy a tomar el color rosa
tenemos el triángulo abed
este de acá y tenemos que 12.5 el
círculo radio 12.5 del círculo radio es
igual al producto de los lados entonces
sería este de aquí que mide 2 a 2
x este de acá estoy acá cuánto mide pues
es la hipotenusa de un triángulo
rectángulo de la 2a y b
entonces me de raíz cuadrada raíz
cuadrada de cuadrada más b cuadrada por
el teorema de pitágoras para entonces
sería 2a x
raíz de cuadrada más b cuadrada
multiplicado por la longitud de a de que
como es un rombo también es raíz de la
cuadra damas b cuadrada más bien
cuadrado entonces sería x raíz de lo
mismo a cuadrada más b cuadrada y eso lo
tenemos que dividir lo tenemos que
dividir entre cuatro veces
cuatro veces el área el área de este
triángulo de aquí pero cuál es el área
de este triángulo bueno pues ya dijimos
que el área de cada uno de los
triangulitos chiquitos es un medio de
ave y aquí tenemos dos de esos
triangulitos entonces el área de advent
es igual a dos veces la mitad de ave o
sea que es igual a por entonces nos
queda cuatro ahora por ve muy bien
déjame simplificar un poco el aceba con
el am el 2 con el 4 se hace un medio
medio y así nos queda que 12.5 es igual
a raíz de la cuadra damas b cuadrada por
sí mismo es cuadrada más b cuadrada a
cuadrada más b cuadrada dividido entre
dos veces dividido entre 2 b muy bien
entonces esta información de que el
circo un círculo del triángulo ave de
tiene radio 12.5 nos da esta ecuación
vale
utilizando la formulita de aquí ahora
vamos con el otro con el otro círculo el
de hace de entonces déjame tomar otro
color digamos este color verde verde
brillante
y vamos a ver qué información nos da el
triángulo así de bueno en este caso
tenemos que 25 25 es igual déjame hacer
el 5 un poco más bonito 25 es igual a
una vez más hay que multiplicar los
lados ahora se mide 2 b entonces es
igual a 2 b 2 2 b
esta x c de que es raíz de la cuadra
damas b cuadrada país cuadrada más b
cuadrada x a de que también es raíz de
cuadrada más b cuadrada ok más b
cuadrada y eso lo tenemos que dividir lo
tenemos que dividir entre 4 veces el
área de acceder pero otra vez hace de
está formado por dos de estos triángulos
congruentes entonces de nuevo esa área
es igual a aa por b
vamos a simplificar el b se cancela con
esteve el 2 con este 4 se hacen dos
abajo y entonces nos queda que 25 25 es
igual a raíz de la cuadra damas b
cuadrada por sí
a cuadra damas b cuadrada dividido entre
dos veces a dos veces
esto está fantástico ya tenemos dos
ecuaciones esta de acá y esta de acá y
tenemos dos incógnitas tenemos a llave
entonces con un poco de suerte ya vamos
a poder resolver este problema
encontrando a y b vale bueno entonces
qué vamos a hacer a ver de este lado
déjame multiplicar déjame a ver voy a
bajar para tener un poco más de espacio
entonces aquí voy a multiplicar por 2 b
de ambos lados por 2 b por 2 b este se
cancela con este aquí nos queda 25 b 25
b es igual
aa cuadrada más b cuadrada y del otro
lado voy a hacer algo similar
voy a multiplicar por 2 y de este lado
por 2 a éste se cancela con este y aquí
nos queda que 50 a es igual a cuadrada
más b cuadrada entonces tenemos dos
formas de poner a la cuadra damas b
cuadrada una es como 25 b entonces 25 b
es igual a cuadrada más b cuadrada pero
eso es igual a 50
entonces 25 b es igual a 50
aquí podemos dividir entre entre 25 de
los dos lados y nos queda que b b es
igual a 2 a 2
y con esta información ya podemos
sustituir b digamos en esta igualdad y
despejar a vale entonces voy a continuar
de este lado tenemos que 50-50
es igual aa cuadrada + b cuadrada pero b
es 2 a 2 al cuadrado entonces 50 a es
igual a a cuadrada más 4 a cuadrada
entonces 50 a 50 a es igual a 5 a
cuadrada y dividiendo entre entre 5 a de
los dos lados porque a no es cero es una
longitud entonces entre dividiendo entre
5 a de los dos lados nos queda que 1010
es igual a a y con esto podemos
determinar el valor de b b es dos veces
entonces b es igual a 20 muy bien ya
tenemos el valor de a y el valor debe
entonces simplemente tenemos que
regresar aquí para encontrar para
encontrar el área
a veces tenemos que el área de abc de es
igual a dos veces a que es 10
x b que es igual a 20 entonces el área
de abc d es igual a 2 por 10 que es 20
20 por 20 que es 400 400 muy bien y con
esto terminamos el problema con esta
información de los radios de las
circunferencias circunscritas obtenemos
que el área del rombo abc de es igual a